sometimes we have to wonder and speculate
how someone comes to hold radical beliefs
or becomes motivated to commit violence in
the real world.
And sometimes the people who do those things
will actually tell us and we've actually figured
that out with the mag of bomber.
The Mag Obama is this 57 year old Florida
man who sent all those a pipe bombs through
the mail to Democrats and was ultimately caught.
You'll remember maybe images of his van covered
in right wing messaging and stickers and he
has told us that he was radicalized by Fox
News along with other right wing media.
He pled guilty to 65 counts back in March
and there's a whole bunch of court documents
that have now been released that are extremely
insightful as well as disturbing to be quite
honest with you and his attorney actually
said his attorneys say through these court
documents that the Mag Obama quote found light
in Donald Trump that he watched fox news quote
religiously and specifically he was watching
Fox and friends in the morning and Hannity
in the evening.
Check out this quote from the court documents.
His infatuation with the president began as
something personal, not political when he
was most down.
Mr Siack relied on self help books on tape
to keep going.
Donald Trump's books on success and business
were his favorites.
Mr [inaudible] was an ardent Trump fan, and
when Trump announced he was running for president,
Mr [inaudible] enthusiastically supported
him.
He began watching Fox News religiously at
the gym, planning his morning workout to coincide
with Fox and friends and his evenings.
To dovetail with Hannity.
He became obsessed with quote attacks from
those he perceived as Trump's enemies.
And the court documents go on to outline that
he was not only radicalized through right
wing media and the Internet, but he used that
same internet to also learn to build the pipe
bombs that he ultimately ended up sending
to Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama, George
Soros, and a number of other people whose
names escape me.
So the real important takeaway here is that
the media stuff is not a game.
Once you understand the concept of stochastic
terrorism, which I've talked about enough
this week, I'm not going to redefine it, but
Google it or check out some of my stories
from earlier this week about it.
When you understand the sort of fundamental
vulnerability of so many people, you really
should have a sense of responsibility for
everything that you say in a public forum,
in media, on TV or in a youtube channel, and
the radicalizing impact of extremist media
is just massive and if you won't listen to
live calls on our show, we've received a lot
of calls from people who call in and say they
were radicalized by, you know, they will sometimes
say it was Alex Jones or info wars, Stefan
Molyneux.
Breitbart could be Fox News, could be the
blaze.
There are less well known ones as well.
I can't think of all of them off hand.
The point is, this is not an exception to
the rule.
The combination of extremely outrageous content
meant to foment anger rather than activism
that benefits the majority of people or that
improve society.
This anger porn that is so popular among particularly
right wing media combined with the echo chamber,
algorithmic, a self perpetuating loops that
people can get into on youtube or another
places, online, Twitter, Facebook, et cetera.
This is meant to give people more and more
of what resonates with them the most and what
we have to understand is that for many people
that self, that constant feedback loop is
going to lead them to take real world action.
This is not me saying, you know, Facebook's
algorithm is a terroristic, I'm not saying
that.
I'm not going that far.
I'm not saying that when Glenn Beck rants
and raves about the tides foundation and someone
goes and tries to shoot up the ties foundation
that now Glen Beck is specifically guilty
of a crime.
What I'm saying is if we want to have an adult
conversation that goes beyond the letter of
the law, we have to understand the responsibility
that we have.
Anytime people are consuming messages that
we put out into the media where you don't
know everyone that's hearing it, right?
When you're at a dinner party and you're talking
to six people, you know who is receiving your
message and you can in real time sort of gauge
their reaction and most people would naturally
kind of tailor their speech to make sense
for the people that they're speaking to.
When I do a segment and 500,000 people watch
it on Youtube, I don't know the mental state
of everybody who's watching.
I don't know the way that everybody is hearing
what I'm saying.
And I take that as a very serious responsibility
to try to speak in a way that is responsible
for, to use that same word, that type of responsibility
is something that seems completely missing
from a lot of these narratives that are crafted
by right wing media and these court documents
tell us exactly
how
it works.